[Music]
young and beautiful most girls you got
to talk about most girls because it is
so addicting it's totally like a girl
power anthem song you know so when you
hear maybe stories of other females not
getting along in this industry like are
you surprised by that when you hear that
I mean look it's always a disappointment
and I think wherever you go whether it's
in this industry or whether it's in a
high school or a middle school or at any
other job there's competition and
there's there's jealousy and there's all
of that and it exists in my life and I
think it's a way of sort of dealing with
it and this song has really been a
realization for me and I think a real
sort of progressive way that a lot of
people men and women are starting to
think in sort of looking at each other
and wanting to be more like each other
wanting to band together and and really
empower and support each other and I
think that I think we're doing that
[Music]
qualities do you appreciate the most in
most girls strength bravery courage
[Music]
you
you